[Music]  hello everyone my name is Noreen Sol I'm  a pianist composer and today we're gonna  go over some ways to sound like Jay s BA  first off we're going to choose a motive  [Music]  let's actually make that a little more  straightforward once we identify our key  Center we're going to get familiar with  four-part harmony with this in mind  we're going to favor polyphony over  homophony in other words multiple lines  make up the harmony rather than having  chords that accompany the melody next  avoid parallel fifths and octaves get  familiar with suspensions  [Music]  use sequences stick with an organized  grid like rhythm use fragments of the  motive especially to have imitations  between the lines embrace dissonance and  chromaticism add ornaments to taste and  now put it all together  [Music]  so I hope you enjoyed that thank you so  much for watching please subscribe if  you haven't already and I'll see you in  the next video